John wake up the spider-man trailer
dropped so early
come on spider miss don't what the hell
are you doing we don't have time for
another 5 minutes sketch come on all
right sorry
[Music]
howdy he'll reject nation I'm Greg Alba
you know I'm John we are gonna watch the
far from home trailer ball us on patreon
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
look how supportive she is I know
therefore I pretty - whoa not Ned Nick
oh wow
Lebanese who is fighting the elementals
[Music]
I mean right off the bat the first thing
I noticed is how much more striking the
cinematography is yeah the color palette
really stands out this time around I
mean it's not like like vibrant colors
but everything's just a lot more
striking yeah in a weird way not the
first movie wasn't big but it looks like
they're like we're going to Europe let's
go Bing with the scope and the scimitar
yeah and I heard that I I did hear that
he was impossible for me to avoid after
this trailer I don't know this is the
same exact one because I didn't read the
breakdown what I heard was that that it
looked like Mysterio and spider-man
we're teaming up we're gonna be working
together yeah and they're gonna be going
up against the elementals and it looks
like that's what we were getting here
yeah bunch of characters that represent
the elements yeah so it would make sense
I guess cuz they said that Nick Fury
hires Mysterio okay
because mister is the one who knows the
best about it but so then by the end
he's gonna go out and strike out on his
own and be a villain or something
I like the main theory that I heard
going around because we run in so many
circles I talked about this the main
theory that I heard going around was
that Mysterio this is all part of his
elaborate plan like he's an illusionist
so this is all just kind of fake and
he's just setting himself up to look
like a hero because that's what he does
I remember from the 90s cartoon a big
part of like how Mysterio tended to
operate to Spiderman looked bad so he
can look like a good guy yeah yeah I was
about to say like what if he's just
conjuring up these yeah informations
because when when Jake Gyllenhaal showed
up and he said that line it sounded a
little cheesy but I think it's supposed
to I feel like I'm playing a hero but I
gotta admit though like when you see
like fishbowl and everything like that
full suit you're like oh damn they
brought it to life oh yeah yes in theory
this trailer did what a good trailer for
a movie like this ought to do where it's
like I just want to see Mysterio right
now I'm not even so concerned with what
the context is gonna be I'm just happy
to see yeah they got the fishbowl ahead
that we have to see him do some pretty
crazy like mystical stuff because
knowing Marvel hopefully that's gonna
get pretty trippy and weird and fun as
well it looks like this is gonna have a
lot more weird fun I mean it obviously
looks like a lot bigger in scope in
terms of its action sequences and
whatnot yeah I mean there's a lot of
eighties in this trailer a happy Hogan
and an Maine yeah the interim may like
practically work I didn't hear anything
about that from Brazil comic god they're
like bonding not what I expect I thought
we're gonna do that cliche route it
should be spider-man anymore
yeah it made your arms way you know it
still makes it oh my contacts acting up
so if I start twitching I'm sorry guys
whoa hey save you and Peter has the same
birthday as my mom and as my as my dad
and sister and by the way my sister
helped out with that opening Skechers
want to shout that out really quick
thank you Edwyn Nick Fury showed up to
that was also like what the hell because
I know he was in this movie but then we
got shot I thought that'd be Mysterio or
the elemental or something like that you
know which is funny
well now I'm wondering like is Nick Fury
gonna be the Tony Stark of this movie
like how present is he gonna be is he
gonna have that sort of like I'm your
uncle kind of watching yeah
Mayans and popping in every 10 minutes
well the timeline wasn't confirmed in
this trailer either of exactly when this
is taking place you know like if it's
another ant-man in the loss situation if
it's right after Avengers 4 Thanos snap
I get your jokes John well plus you got
two cool new looking suits from
spider-man here little black one and you
got the one that's like red and black
yeah but literally when I scan this
trailer it's like this the
cinematography just looks so much better
because I guess that was a missing
element for me from homecoming I like
the tone and I like the style but in
terms of the way it was captured it was
like you know yeah and here you're like
oh there's a signature style to this
approach this time around yeah it seems
like they're pretty conscientious about
how to punch up each movie moving
forward yeah yeah and weirdly the the
stinger joke with Tony River lorry like
- yeah totally idolizing spider-man of
being a dick to Peter like got me pretty
pretty good that was a funny one I
forgot he was in this movie surprise
really that's right all of you guys cuz
I mainly remember Peter Parker and Ned I
know the I don't know like don't know
who the elementals are from like reading
comics and stuff but I know there are
actual villains
I guess my one question is if this is
part of Mysterio's like illusion does
that mean it's another kind of Mandarin
situation really gonna happen is
Mysterio's gonna conjure up these fake
elementals and then it's very end post
credits scene the real elementals are
gonna hear about and be like well this
sucks
totally stealing our thunder let's be
the villains in spider-man 3 and you
know then people will be underwhelmed
they already saw those villains in this
movie fair enough all right guys well um
transition before we wrap this video up
I would like to give a patron the day
shout out to a man named Jake Stewart
who is fairly new patron and new
follower of the real rejects only found
us about a couple months ago actually
found me our movie fights John oh boy
that's right
homeboys from Illinois he is an
assistant coach and a radio broadcaster
at his local high school coach from a
town of about 400 people so he knows
everybody and sleeps with everybody of
age he is only 21 blowing through town
project that literally he's great or he
is be whatever living the dream and so
far from talking with the guy he's very
support gentleman is a very very kind
man and now that you're 21 go live it up
my friend go meet all 400 people in that
city
that's the adventurous life right there
see if you can get with everybody that's
never been done before yeah you could do
it it's like within your reach he likes
being there what he doesn't like doing
is going far from home spider-man spider
film anyway guys you can subscribe to
the reject nation click that
notification bell and check us out on
patreon we do weekly q and A's and also
TV show reaction watch along for many
shows including attack on Titan my hero
academia Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood Riverdale Gotham and
supernatural and he does music video
coverage so go check us out today and
see if you want to become a patron eject
thanks guys